[Música]
nacimos nacimos para morir nos conocimos
para vivir la pregunta que en este
momento es sumamente importante que nos
hagamos todos millones de personas en
este mundo todos los días la gente sale
de sus hogares con la idea firme de
encontrar razones para vivir otras para
morirse
lo importante es hacernos la pregunta si
verdaderamente y no estoy aquí pendiente
de llevar una vida o pendiente y llevar
una sobrevivencia un buen porcentaje de
los seres humanos en este país y en este
mundo están sobreviviendo a sus propias
historias de vida a sus propios
patrimonios a sus propios trabajos es
triste como un alto porcentaje está
saliendo todos los días de su casa para
encontrar lo que necesita otros otros
están descubriendo otras maneras y otros
salen al mundo no a tener obtener lo que
necesitan lo que se merecen y entre el
hombre en la grande
yo creo que este mundo nos está
obligando la misma sociedad se está
llevando a hacernos este planteamiento a
preguntarnos una y otra una vez más si
las reformas que se están haciendo desde
los gobiernos son las que verdaderamente
estamos necesitando yo yo soy un
convencido que lo más importante que hoy
le hace falta a este mundo es la reforma
personal ese instante esa decisión donde
nos atrevamos a cambiar el rumbo de la
historia sin esperar a que alguien venga
a hacerlo por nosotros es difícil
comprender como todavía hay muchas
personas que están esperando que se haga
el milagro el wardi para construir
cuentan las personas que están esperando
que alguien venga y les haga feliz
verdad en lugar de asumir la
responsabilidad de crear esas razones
esas razones para sentirme pleno para
sentirme realizado para sentirme feliz
hoy en occidente la llamamos depresión
un mal que nos aqueja un mal que nos
está atacando a todos los días y nos
roba la posibilidad de tomar esas
grandes
nos estamos ocupando de cosas que nos
permiten verdaderamente sentirnos vivos
y hemos caído sin querer el es inercia
de esperar que llegue de afuera algo que
traemos desde alem merece la pena que
nos detengamos un momento merece la pena
que nos sentemos a platicar con el
interlocutor más importante con uno
mismo y hacernos la pregunta si
verdaderamente yo estoy dejando huella
vivir vivir con los elementos básicos
los más sencillos los más honestos
pasión creatividad valor darle darle un
sentido a nuestra vida casi todos los
que estamos aquí porque todos tenemos un
trabajo el problema no es que tengamos
son un trabajo la gran pregunta tendría
que ser si además del trabajo yo tengo
un sentido en mi vida
si yo tengo una misión el divide
los mexicanos dos morimos expectativa de
vida en este país es para las mujeres de
77 años y para los hombres de 74
nos queda mucho tiempo digo no veo no
veo a todos por el promedio del grupo de
hacer de 30 años y la gran pregunta que
tendríamos que hacernos o podíamos
hacernos es en qué voy a gastar los
otros cuarenta y tantos años no voy a
vivir o como quiero vivir o que deseo
que suceda alrededor de mi historial
personal
estoy aquí para dejar huella vivir con
la suficiente pasión ese valor tan
importante el valor de trascender verdad
no lo voy a hacer de tal manera para que
me pueda quedar en ti y seguiré estando
cuando ya no esté estamos en una
sociedad tan rápida tan deprisa donde
pareciera que lo único que importa es
satisfacer la necesidad del propio día y
se nos olvida que hay otras dimensiones
hay otros momentos y hay otros espacios
situaciones que nos confrontan y el
momento también en la historia de cada
uno de nosotros donde merece la pena que
los detengamos y nos preguntemos si lo
que he hecho hasta mi año 50 o 40 ó 30
le han permitido llegar a un invierno de
mi vida con las herramientas con los
recursos suficientes para sentirme
tranquilo y satisfecho el diagrama de la
vida lo que nos va a garantizar ser
feliz es ser hacer y tener otra vez esta
sociedad a veces esta dinámica nos
enseña sobre todo a nuestros niños a
nuestros jóvenes que hay que tener a ser
más o menos y él se les va los viejitos
hoy la vida nos está dictando pautas
distintas y otra vez tendría que ser un
pensamiento reflexivo desde adentro una
autocrítica
estoy siendo estoy haciendo puesto en
teniendo
muchos optan por lo más económico sufrir
que es una decisión
muchos están lamentándose la situación
muchos están condenados al pasado y se
sientan en una silla en un sillón y
hacen incluso del dolor de ese pasado
doloroso una zona de confort
hay millones de personas en este mundo
sentado plácidamente esperando que el
pasado cambie para ser felices
uno de los grandes absurdos los gramos
de hubiéramos nos llenamos de
situaciones que nos formulan una
revancha una revancha estar culpando o
estarnos minimizar la situación la
situación más cómoda que podemos
encontrar en este gran diagrama también
debemos descubrir y hacer nuestro algo
sumamente importante generar razones
razones que dependen directamente del
sentido que le demos a nuestra propia
historia de vida razones para que
primero para creer hay quien quiere ir
en un mundo donde tanta gente desconfía
donde la confianza se vuelve en un
activo tan inalcanzable a veces
yo creo que tenemos que regresar a ese
punto decir necesito creer en el amor
necesito creer en la familia necesito
creer en las instituciones es que no hay
nada que te puede dar a creer entonces
tu conviértete en esa familia
conviértete en ese empresario
conviértete en ese político que sea
digno digno de que se le crea razones
para creer
en el mañana razones para creer en la
gente
el segundo grupo de razones es razones
para esperar sobre todo otra vez sobre
todo con las nuevas generaciones hoy los
niños y los jóvenes están muy aburridos
porque les hemos dado demasiadas cosas
demasiado rápido demasiado pronto y
entonces nos hacemos por comodidad del
adulto los hacemos también a ellos
adultos jóvenes les estamos arrebatando
la capacidad de esperar y correr y buena
y muchos se atoran en los calores
y muchos centró piezas porque no están
preparados para hacer esos movimientos
tan bruscos incluso violentos y por
último razones para amar empezando por
uno mismo sin contarnos mentiras
hay dos cosas que a este mundo sobre
todo el hemisferio latinoamericano lo
tiene muy complicado los sucesivos que
son los malos gobiernos a veces creemos
que es la corrupción a veces creemos que
la situación geográfica política de
quien venimos aquí nos punto yo creo que
a estas alturas del partido tendríamos
que convencernos es una responsabilidad
que le formamos ha subido del todo
razones para amar dejarnos de contar
mentiras dejar de simular las
situaciones hacernos dueños de nuestro
propio nuestro propio destino y entender
que estamos aquí para construir a partir
de este momento el día más hermoso para
vivir se es hoy
pero mucha gente que sigue añorando el
día que no fue el día que no pasó el día
que no ha llegado y entonces vive en su
día de hoy en la amargura pensando que
hoy se van a morir
tenemos todavía mucho por construir a
veces hay que inventarnos e incluso hay
que inventarnos
hay que poner una razón al mañana
razones para amar un sueño una ilusión
una persona una emoción una situación un
proyecto interpretados porque no ha sido
capaz de enamorarse el ser humano pero
mantenga
bien
creo yo que es el momento propicio para
darnos cuenta de que podemos hacer eso y
cambiar esa historia en nuestros países
y cambiar esa historia en nuestro mundo
romper el paradigma las dos cosas que
nos tienen de rodillas no son y los
dolores no son y la pobreza
la autocompasión y el machismo pobrecito
méxico por citó latinoamericana
pobrecito
dejemos este pobre piano porque cada vez
que decimos pobrecito estamos diciendo a
la otra persona que es un ser inferior y
eso es un acto de vida
y es interior la que tendría que
sentirse inferior a nadie y a veces
somos nosotros como padres de familia
como educadores como líderes quienes
estamos diciéndole a los demás a
nuestros seguidores a nuestros hijos a
nuestros alumnos se les inferior
con pasión que no nos ayuda a alcanzar
ese grado del que nos merecemos en
nuestra dignidad humana y lo otro es el
machismo con todo
creer que los hombres estamos en
competencia y que además debemos ganarle
a las mujeres
una de las grandes deudas que tenemos en
este mundo la tenemos con la mujer ella
que intentamos que las mujeres son
nuestro complemento y que en muchas
ocasiones son nuestro impulso incluso
nuestra razón de ser ese día vamos a
tener una sociedad más justa y
verdaderamente
no se trata de porcentajes se trata de
respeto se trata de entenderte como otro
ser humano que tienes tanto que
aportarle a mi vida como yo a tu vida
vamos vamos a hacer un acto reflexivo y
que en ese acto represivo seamos capaces
de darnos cuenta que no somos al día de
hoy 10 de febrero del 2018
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos
y romper el paradigma es latinoamérica
es méxico
ubícate aquí se empieza tarde aquí se
permite el papel aquí se permite la
mordida aquí se permite la producción
vamos a ubicarnos en la presencia del
ser humano y entender que yo soy llamado
hace mucho más de lo que ello hasta el
día de hoy vamos a convertirnos en la
mejor versión de nosotros mismos
soy un convencido que en la historia del
ser humano
hay muchos capítulos hay muchas
historias con finales felices esas las
escriben los guionistas otras con
finales necesarios
no será que tú y yo ya llegamos a ese
punto donde tengamos que ponerle
dominar a una historia
no será que ya llegó el momento de
despertar verdaderamente las conciencias
y los más allá de la emoción y los más
allá del corazón y conectar con la razón
combinar perfectamente razón y acción se
llama sabiduría verdad y empezar a
verdaderamente construir estamos aquí
para construir
dejemos el trauma dejamos el complejo
teatre vamos a convertirlos en la mejor
versión de nosotros mismos estamos aquí
para ser felices
cualquiera que diga lo contrario se
puede estar despedir
para ser felices y la condición donde
nacimos no debería marcar la condición
donde vamos a morir
tenemos setenta y tantos años para tomar
esa opción para decidir
ese es mi pasado y el pasado es
inalterable yo construyo
a historias con finales felices
con finales necesarios yo tengo que
poner
[Aplausos]